but mate i'm joined here by with ajeet
rya again um mate stoke to have you back
on uh thanks for reaching out i know you
um
felt like you had a little bit more to
talk about than uh
we first sort of spoke about the first
time you came on so
appreciate you reaching out and willing
to come back on
yeah mate it's uh of course uh it's
always great to you know be on the show
and talking to you and
um
yeah i just wanted to be very you know
transparent and kind of open up a little
bit more on
the journey of a tennis player because
it's all well and good to speak about
the highs and
how exciting it is but i you know kind
of wanted to have some real talk and
you know the journey i've been on and
come through and the battles i've had to
overcome
um on the way
yeah mate awesome i'm looking forward to
this because right finishing that
episode uh listening back to it i was
like man you're such an easy guy to talk
to you got so much so much good energy
about you um i felt like i'd known you
for years even though we'd never met
before and then to hear that you have
been suffering with mental health issues
and things like that
would never have picked up on that from
that episode
yeah i think it's the beautiful thing
about having a mask yeah um
i think it's
you know it
was great that it like you can hide it
for so long but then it starts you know
it's you know the pressure cooker starts
uh overflowing and
i just
you know if i can
inspire any kid to play tennis was a
dream of mine and if i can help any kid
and realize that they're not alone um
then
you know it's
it's also quite a
like edgy dangerous topic to also talk
about because
it's very personal and when you feel
you're talking about something personal
you feel you're most vulnerable
so i've only really spoken to
my close family and friends about this
and you know day by day i could talk to
one extra person about it and was
comfortable at the start i couldn't talk
to anyone about it no matter who was
closest to me
um
and now i feel i'm
comfortable to speak about it because i
would like to think that those battles
are in my rear vision mirror
and
i'm looking at going forward and
improving myself as a person as a player
and mentally more than anything
so
yeah i just want to share kind of my
journey and if i can help anyone on the
way and anyone can
realize that they're not alone as as
lonely as it feels then
you know uh
that would
you know that's one of my goals tipped
off
right hundred percent i appreciate you
coming on and being so open and
vulnerable because i know how many um
listeners get so much out of this it's
such a common
common thing these days people suffer
with mental health
and from the little episodes we've
touched on it so far the amount of
messages i get back from people who can
relate and how much they get out of it
i know it doesn't go unnoticed so mate
really appreciate you coming on and
being open and vulnerable to talk about
that but
mate how did it how did it start when
did you when did you know
so
20 i think it was 2019 or 2018 you know
i won my first pro title everything was
going great um
yeah i was going up the rankings and
everything was all positive started
getting a few more sponsors so i got a
bit more financial help which means i
could play more tournaments
and then i was in the gym um
about a week before i was heading to
africa for four events and
i was you know squatting in the gym and
i'm not the strongest guy but i was just
trying to you know stick to my program
and
i felt a spasm in my back
um the spasm started spreading i
was
you know bedridden for a couple days and
they told me it was my facet joint and
when it got treatment they clipped it
back into place felt good as new went to
africa caught that 19 hour flight to
dubai and then six hours to kampala in
uganda where i was playing four events
where my dad was actually born and he
was a refugee so he wanted to take me
back there to play some tournaments
and my first hit i was heading with
one of my irish friends uh simon carr
he's a good player and we were training
together and
i
went for like a quick reflex volley and
i felt the same spasm in my back
um
now
i have come all this way i'm so far away
from home
um i've got four events i'm gonna play
them that's how i thought i
you know the injuries
that
i had i never was injured so it was like
walk it off put some ice on it chuck a
band-aid on you're fine you know um my
dad also he was a refugee from
africa so he's pretty you know he's
pretty tough and
injuries don't come close to what he
came through so
he you know he
my body was always looked after i never
got injured i never had any issues and
now when i had this back problem
i kept playing on it and playing on it
until
about week two so i played the first
week and then in the second week i woke
up couldn't feel my left foot couldn't
move my toes
um couldn't feel anything in my left
foot
absolutely numb and
i went to top my shoelaces that morning
to go train and i'm going you know like
pull my shoelaces and i yank my back and
i feel like an electric shock through my
body
and
my whole nerve system is just like
it's just strangling and if
i went to say kick a rugby ball like
stretch that hamstring my left one
felt like barbed wire was turning in my
back like it just the nerve was just
pulling so it was my sciatic nerve so i
got home went straight to the physios
they got me an mri yup you have a
bulging disc or a disc protrusion and
it's jamming on the nerve
so you can't play
so i'm like what do you mean i can't
play like it's an injury a couple weeks
or something they're like no you're
gonna be out of action for two three
months by the time your rehab's finished
so
then two three months comes up i go to
play my first match back i'm done on my
rehab i was playing in new zealand
i go for a smash and i feel it and it
compresses
and the same thing happens and i jam the
nerve again and i'm like no chance like
i'm just not gonna tell anyone so i'm
going to keep taking
painkillers and keep taking voltarans
and keep just trying to you know get
through if the physios ask me can you do
this yup i was so drugged up when i went
to the physios like on painkillers not
drugs i don't do any drugs like i mean
like pain killers um
i was so heavy like on painkillers that
i couldn't feel it so if they tried to
test me i was like feel good as new so
they cleared me to play
and ended up being like
nine months
um after the nine month period so i
heard it and then i got injured in three
months then it kept getting injured at
the nine month period i just said to
them look i can't play anymore i'm just
in too much pain they're like what do
you mean you've been fine i'm like look
this is what i've been taking so i was
taking this all the time as soon as i
felt it basically
couldn't driving her playing tennis hurt
didn't really play any golf because that
would have been the worst thing for us i
was just in pain all the time um
so then when i was out for you know and
i couldn't play
i realized that
no one really spoke to me
um some sponsors didn't want to know me
they they dropped me yeah um
no one really
knew who ajit was without tennis it was
always just tennis tennis tennis it was
always oh you're the tennis player oh
okay uh we know you you're the tennis
player tennis this tennis that so
without tennis no one messaged me no one
called me i realized that i was actually
quite lonely
i hadn't built any relationships with my
mates back then i hadn't tried to build
a thai unit i hadn't reached out to my
mates it was all on me but i just hadn't
really reached out to anyone because i
thought that the people who were close
to me like my sponsors and stuff oh i
have some great sponsors but at the time
the people who were close to me
weren't really close to me they were
close to me doing well which is
absolutely fine but that's just life
um you know everyone loves a winner
that's just how it is
and
in the country of
new zealand
being okay at tennis or being number one
in the country gets you some recognition
that's just how it is because it's a
small country
and
i just tied all my self-worth to tennis
so
at the time i didn't realize what it was
i just thought that okay i need to get
back on court because
i'm not a person without tennis i need
to get back on court and i need to start
winning
so i'd be practicing unbelievable but in
matches
it would start happening that i'd start
getting like a really tight chest in
matches i couldn't breathe i would go to
the back of the court and i just felt
like i was you know this big and the
core was huge i would start you know hot
like not hyper ventilating but i just
felt like i couldn't get air in like i
just felt like i was literally just like
locked up i was like breathing through a
straw and this is playing a professional
sport um but in practice i was
absolutely fine my back was fine
everything was fine because there's no
result so
it was all tied to result and it was all
tied to you know being
a tennis player and being achieving all
of that was my identity or i thought
and you know my dad always tried to tell
me that you know your tennis is your
tennis and your you
we love you
we don't care if you play tennis but i
was like yeah okay sweet like i'm gonna
be world number one i'm gonna be top
hundred in the world all the i had all
these goals and if i didn't reach them i
was a bad person because i failed at
what i tried to do
so
then it got worse and worse last year in
tunisia when i was over there playing
and i was stuck there and then
when um you know some things happened
around uh
you know davis cup and decisions were
made and um
you know they made decisions which was
best for the team and that's fine and i
didn't make the team um last year and
that
also added to it and it just kept
building up and up and i would lose
matches and you know i would have a bad
den i'm ready to talk about it then the
next day i'd win a match and then you're
like oh okay look i just had a good day
now so
i'm actually fine like i'm just gonna
ride this high and
you know i'll talk about it later i'll
talk about it later
and
then um i came to la in january
and
in december didn't play a whole lot of
tennis was doing a lot of physical work
with my trainer got in good shape but
didn't play a lot of tennis and
when you aren't playing in the sport you
can't even
it's like when you're in it you feel
like you're like nearly hallucinating
like you're imagining things and then
when you leave it and leave the triggers
like you go away from them you can't
even remember those thoughts you can't
remember the feelings but as soon as you
go into those feelings again or into
you know uh
where you're triggered by it it's like
coming straight back to you and you
can't you're like i'll never forget this
feeling but then as soon as you go away
and you
go and you're you're with your you know
some of your friends at the beach or
you think everything's good you think
everything's fine just a tough day in
the office
um and then i came back to la and i was
playing in close to l.a and i had just
had a massive panic attack and
you know i went back into um into the
car and i was just you know a lot of
emotion and just didn't know what to do
and i picked up the phone and
i called my parents and i was like what
do i do this is what's been happening
for the last and you know
of course mum she you know would blame
herself she thought it was her fault i
was like this is no one's fault this is
me this is on me i just haven't want to
talk to anyone i put on this mask off
i'm a happy guy everything's great and
but it comes a point where it just
becomes
too tough and i had to get to rock
bottom to understand that
and
then when i uh
finished in la
i started working with a psychologist
here
and for a week i just stayed in my room
i actually got really really sick during
that period um
we're not sick as in like not eating and
stuff but i just got like a really bad
flu from stress during that time yeah
and i had to pull out of tournaments and
i you know i genuinely thought it was
cover but i kept testing negative wasn't
covered um
and i just you know was in this room
where i am now because i'm in san diego
um where i actually have a really good
base and i was just in the room for a
week and didn't want to leave i just was
my happiest when it got to about 6 p.m
and it was dark and i could just sit in
my room and just be not hassled and just
be by myself and that was my happiest
um
and my parents you know they wanted to
fly over and i was like look
i started working with a psychologist
and it's kind of something i needed to
do on my own um
and
with the psychologist kind of the things
we started working on was you know
vegeta is a g and tennis is tennis and i
am
you know i'm i'm human i'm meant to be
i'm a good i think i'm a good brother
i'm a good friend um you know i've got
plenty of things i need to work on but
i'm
a person outside of tennis tennis is
what i do not who i am
and
when i kind of
started talking to people about it one
by one weight was just being lifted off
my shoulders like i actually like
just couldn't stop smiling when i
started talking to people about it and
they were kind of looking at me like why
are you smiling i'm like you don't
understand how good this feeling is like
i can actually speak to someone about it
and
it was the best feeling ever and now
um you know i lose tennis matches i win
tennis matches but i
feel like a five-year-old kid again
playing tennis down at the courts with
my dad that's the feeling i have
every time i get up i'm so excited to
play because it's the sport i love but i
got to a point where i hated it so much
because of where i was at mentally i
just if i i was so scared to lose a
tennis match that i was like terrified
if the ball came back
if the ball came back i was just so
scared and you would start
self-sabotaging you would you know
all this stuff like it was just
it's a downward spiral and the weird
thing is that now that i'm addressing
[Music]
things i need to address and i'm talking
to people there's i feel a lot less
pressure on myself
the only pressure i feel on myself is
that i wake up and give my 100 of my
idea of success used to be win this when
there
get this sponsored get that sponsor all
a relevant
bs
and now
my idea of success is
being in my bed at the end of the night
and saying i just put in a really good
day's day off work and i'm satisfied i
had my list i have my things i do every
morning i go into my diary and write
what i need to get done and i've ticked
it off and that's my idea of success now
and
if i in my career and
i
don't get any better than i am now but i
gave it my all then i'm absolutely fine
with that because i've done everything
in my control and and my process to do
that
and
i
am probably
the most i'm prouder of myself that i'm
come through what i have rather than won
any tennis match or done anything that's
the most that's the most
joy and high i've got in my life was
looking back and being like
yeah i just completely i won that battle
that's the mo that's the battle that was
most important to me so i
i mean that's my journey it could sound
if people know me they'll be like
zero chance this is like what's happened
like they can whatever they think
because i'm just anyone who talks to me
i'm a positive guy like that's how i try
to be
um you know i try to talk [ __ ] i just
try to be positive i just try to have a
good time i don't take life too
seriously but
that's the only way i could keep people
here
by acting like i just didn't care about
anything until
you know now my relationship with my
family has gotten a lot better i was
just back home for two weeks
um two or three weeks and i probably had
the best time i've ever had being back
in new zealand
um
my real you know my parents and my
relationship is amazing my relationship
my brother and sister is really good
i talk to them every day i just you know
i just
am so
filled with kind of like joy of life and
that doesn't mean that okay you're done
you've got to keep improving and you've
got to keep improving
but
i mean that's kind of the conversations
i've been having was this very one with
my closest people around me so i just
kind of
the reason
i thought it was time is because i
thought this is a platform where
if anyone out there is
struggling with the same way or having
the same thoughts that
there's always a way to improve and get
better and
where people say it's not you know it's
not weak to speak and all of this i also
think that you can't tell someone
to speak you can't tell but you can tell
someone to feel the way you feel
it's okay to absolutely feel the way you
want to feel and
you might not have to speak up
but
i think acting on it is the biggest
bravery you know acting and on on it as
in like improving
is the biggest
that's showing true like true heart i
think and a cheesy way of saying
so
yeah that's kind of kind of where things
are at for me right now mate there's so
much in there and you mentioned about
the mask and stuff and obviously the
last podcast i did with you didn't pick
up any of it but listening to you speak
now and hearing some of those things
you're talking about going back to you
know being injured you mentioned in the
podcast the earlier one where um
when you're injured you don't get paid
and then hearing you talk about
everyone's sort of dropping off your
not wanting to know you anymore because
you're the tennis player and things like
that and all that extra pressure on you
to be this successful tennis player and
you i remember you talking about how
lonely it is uh traveling by yourself
living by yourself and it's always you
have to be your own best friend so
remembering back to some of those things
and then hearing you speak here a lot of
it all what makes way more sense because
it must be such a hard sport and you see
it throughout all a lot of individual
sports on how hard some of these uh
we've seen it in the cycling and the
olympics and things like that a lot of
people are i'm taking their lives in in
these sports because there's so much
pressure on them to succeed and they
feel isolated they're by themselves and
it's so powerful to hear this um coming
from you
i mean i think a lot of the athletes of
you know
because a lot of the time i would search
up and
you know you'd search up on the internet
and stuff you'll be like is this normal
because you don't feel normal you feel
broken that's how you feel you literally
feel like
you're broken and
you never expect these things as a kid i
mean when you're a kid when you
start playing the sport till you're 16
you hear of stories like this and you're
like
that's just not me that won't happen to
me like there's no way i'd get to that
you know but you think that it's just so
far away and it's so far fished it's
like
stuff like the current events that
happen around the world you just don't
think you'll be involved in it
and
then when it happens then when it
happens to you
you kind of feel like you're the
you're one of them you're broken but
then when you
realize and come through it
i don't really care what anyone else
says because i'm happy that's all that
matters i know that i have a family that
loves me i have friends that love me i
have a good coaching team
i have sponsors that have my back and
that's
all i need to be honest that's all i
need
um
all the
i also think it was half
i think it was self-inflicted as in the
sense that my goals were wrong growing
up because
you see
you always look at the top and you look
at other top people live and you want to
live like that you want to drive nice
cars and you want to
you know wear nice things and you want
to go to nice places but man
i i was about to swear but sorry but
just work for it like work for it
it doesn't come by
acting because it just ends up punishing
you in the long run and that's what i
learned the hard way and i'm absolutely
fine to admit that and
my parents might see this and probably
blast me maybe for
you know speaking about it but it's
i'm just one thing i'm starting to do is
go with my gut feeling and if i can help
someone out there that's all i want to
do um
that's all i want to do i want some one
to
see this and be like okay look i can
i can
talk about it or i can act on it and
be brave and make a difference to myself
and
then they can make a difference to
someone and they can make a difference
to someone and it goes forward it's a
domino effect and everyone keeps helping
everyone and there's just
this massive community of people helping
each other i don't understand why you
know
when i was injured it was oh yeah you're
oh you could have been oh yeah you were
like maybe the next best singles player
in new zealand or you could have been
winning tournaments but now you're
injured and it was like oh you're
someone even called me broken at a
tennis center i went in there they're
like oh you're broken now aren't you
you're not playing much and i was like
yeah cheers mate i'm real broken
that helps
and that's coming from people at your
own country which is absurd the rest of
the world's already trying to beat you
and now you've got people in your own
country people bringing each other down
just doesn't make sense how low did it
get for you what was what was the what'd
the worst look like for you did you did
you contemplate taking your life was it
that bad and how did you get through it
um
yeah i mean those thoughts i never i'm
completely honest i never would have
acted on those thoughts but i had those
thoughts all the time
um never would have acted on them
because
i know that i have a family that loves
me and i see the way my mum
acts when i leave the house to go for a
tennis tournament so
i
you know i have a very loving family and
i think it's
again
everyone's hurting but i just don't
think
it's strong doing that and i don't want
to say the wrong thing here and don't
want to come across like i'm being an
absolute
dick but
i just don't think it's strong to do
that because i think it affects a lot of
people
you
taking your own life affects
you um you know you might think it
affects you but it affects a lot of
people in the process and a lot of
people around you
because every person has someone there
and the lowest it got is that i just
didn't want
i don't even think this is low but i
just didn't want to get out of bed ever
like i just wanted to stay there the
whole time like i would get days when
i and i'm a morning person i like to get
up early and get stuff done i wouldn't
get out of bed till 4pm i would just
stay in bed the whole day
and i used to post
instagrams of me playing tennis
when i was in bed so that sponsors and
stuff would think i was training
but i was just in bed and didn't want to
leave
so
that's
pretty much how bad it how how bad it
got um
i was actually very lucky i had uh out
of anyone i don't know if you'll get
upset that i'm mentioning his name but
anton
um leonard brown who
has been like a older brother to me and
i
actually called him when i was in the
states area at a very low point because
i knew of the battles he
has faced and he's you know opened up
about the battles he's faced
and
i called him and
you know
he
was just unbelievable to talk to in the
sense he made of things not that it
changed anything but the thing it
changed as it got me up and wanting to
make a change
so
i think having role models like that
it's not the fact that they play a
professional sport it's the fact that
they're there for you at rock bottom
and now i know that the people who are
there for me at rock bottom
whether i get to world number one
whether i
stop playing tennis tomorrow those
people are going to be with me for the
rest of my life
so cool so um what is it what does that
look like from obviously antoine leonard
brown like obviously a lot of people
know people who are suffering
always tricky to know how to help what
to say
um so what did it look like for you or
what would you recommend for people in
your position
i think
just constantly talking to them not
i think one text saying are you okay how
are you going
is not
um
kind of the way to go i know it's from a
good place and it's good attention but i
feel it's like
you know it's like a little concrete
wall and you've got a little hammer and
you just gotta keep going until that
wall breaks
and
i was very lucky because the hardest
thing is the effort to talk about it
it just feels like
it's such an effort but if someone keeps
talking to you keeps talking to you and
keeps pestering you and then you go mate
i'm not okay i'm actually not all good
things are not great
and that's when they can talk about it
but if i haven't talked to someone in
six months and i go hey bro are you okay
do you really think that guy's gonna
talk to you i don't know
personally i wouldn't
i you know if i had a message from
someone i haven't talked to in a year
and he goes hey man are you okay i'm not
gonna open up to him
but if i have someone for who's
constantly messaging me how are you how
are you how are you maybe even comes and
visits you house things knows you have
his back
then he could then i would open up to
him if that does that make sense yeah
100 so how did you get the courage to
sort of push through it and have the
courage to ring up like an all black ant
on leonard brown and tell him tell him
how you really felt
well i'm
i'm also lucky that anton
has helped me a lot for the past two
years you know i've had a good group of
those rugby boys who have had my back
for the last couple years and
anton was just the one who's been
like a big brother to me that i i knew
that
whatever time of day if i called him
he'll pick up the phone and he'll
he'll talk to me about it
um
and
i'm just very grateful he was he was
there
um
for me to talk to me and he
kind of gave me the courage that hey
look if he
is
able to talk about it then why can't you
know he doesn't
the way i look at him i don't know about
anyone else but when someone talks about
it i'm like man that guy has balls
that's how i that's how i see it i'm so
stoked that that guy's trying to make a
change and i understand people who don't
want to talk about it though because
it's
a very
sensitive thing and it's very it makes
you feel vulnerable and that vulnerable
feeling is like
you're sitting out in a
you're you're in a massive field and
you've got guns pointed at you that's
how you feel
you feel like you could get shot at any
time you've shown you've shown everyone
your cards now it's up to them what they
do with them that's how it feels
and
i i guess back to your question is that
i'm just very lucky that i've had
constant support by him if i didn't
if i hadn't talked to anyone or hadn't
he hadn't known you know because i've
had conversations with him about this in
the past and he's helped me a lot around
mindset but
if i didn't talk to anyone or didn't
talk to him for
a year i wouldn't pick up the phone and
call him
yeah
i'm just uh you know i'm just lucky and
now
you know i was lucky you know that's why
i
i think my results in thailand were kind
of
the most rewarding because it showed
that the process i'm sticking to is
working and the things i'm doing and the
way i'm approaching my matches is
you know i'm just gonna go out there and
i'm gonna stick to my process and i'm
gonna go to a war and if my opponent
beats me
credit to him too good
i'll
get up tomorrow and do it all again you
know
i might have a tantrum i might be upset
i'm
far from perfect if anyone knows me far
from it
but
one thing i'm trying to do now is just
i'm just very process driven and i'm
very lucky that
i know what that looks like because a
lot of people would talk to me about it
until you really
know the effects of not sticking to a
process you won't stick to it i feel
that's i had to be at rock bottom until
i got myself out and
my parents gave me every opportunity
under the sun you know they were the
most loving parents in the world they
are the most loving parents in the world
but
i couldn't take any opportunity i
couldn't act on anything because i was
not at peace with who i was as a person
and
how i was acting and it had to all
collapse until i could rebuild
so what coping mechanisms have you got
going forward so let's say you get
another back spasm you're out for nine
months or something how do you think
you'd deal with that differently this
time around
well that's the
the thing that like you know i've had
injuries and stuff but there's always an
area of you to improve yourself
um
and then you can come back a better
person and a better player you know it's
not about the quantity of tennis you
play it's the quality of tennis you play
and
i think that's probably the biggest
thing is that i
now know that every time you know for
example i never wanted to have a rest
day on my 21st birthday i had two drinks
and then when ran 21 kilometers at like
two in the morning because i felt guilty
um
and
now i understand that if you have a rest
day you can stretch you can do your yoga
you can
get better you can work on your wrist
strength you can work on your ankle
mobility you can work on your neck
mobility i don't know you can there's
there's always areas to improve on but
the biggest one is like when i went home
and i wasn't playing much tennis but i
was doing a lot of physical work
i
you know i can work on myself
i can work on myself i can pick up the
phone
i can
you know today i had lunch with my
psychologist i can
and we might not even talk about
anything we didn't really even talk
about
tennis today or we didn't talk about
coping or anything today or the coping
mechanisms or anything i just it was
good to have lunch with someone that
you're connected with
you know it doesn't have to be a session
every time you don't have to
be doing that type of stuff but just
having the
the freedom to be who you are and who
you want to be is the best feeling in
the world hey so good mate so good and
is it common in tennis do you know many
other tennis players who are suffering
as well or have suffered
i know a lot of tennis players that have
dealt with it a lot that i called during
that time
to ask them a lot of players
i lean lean on as they're my closest
friends and i won't name
who um but
a lot of them who you would see them and
you're like this guy's rock solid
they're not
and
everyone just deals with things
differently but
the reason i
look at them and i'm like i really want
to
i really admire what you're doing is
because they're always looking to
improve themselves and maybe they didn't
get to rock bottom maybe they caught
themselves halfway maybe they don't
suffer from it
um each person's on their own journey
and you can't compare
but you can ask people
if they had the same thing as you what
happened how did you deal with it
so i think it's a very common thing with
any sport because of how the public and
the media and everyone you know tries to
they always paint a portrait of who you
want to be or who not who you want to be
or who they want you to be
and
i just think
you know there's
it's pretty rare that you see
a lot of people praise someone for doing
something good as soon as someone does
something a little bit bad it's let's
pull them down let's get it out there
let's
you know if
the guys i look to are here and i'm here
you know i want to be there but i feel
like a lot of the time people try to
bring this person down
and
uh i know a lot of tennis players that
have dealt with it and
you know i
i think a lot of people do deal with it
but i don't think a lot of people speak
out about it because they're not
comfortable too and that's absolutely
fine this has been a
three four month coping process i've
been on
so you know i started
you know i suffered from it for
two three years and then spoke about it
for the first time in january that
doesn't mean that every single day was a
bad day
but
the bad days became worse every time
crazy and how much did social media play
a part you mentioned a little bit about
posting while you're in your dark room
did social media have a big effect
obviously everyone paints these perfect
lives and um
social media did as in the fact that
i tried to be someone i wasn't on social
media and i'm absolutely fine to
admit that i tried to be
uh
someone he absolutely wasn't and now
i just post whatever i want i don't post
nearly as much as i used to
um
because
of the fact that
my close mates know where i am my
family and friends know what i'm up to
so
you might have
contract obligations with people
that you have to
um
you know you have to post but i'm
my sponsors are amazing and i'm loyal to
them and they're loyal to me and
i've got very very good partnerships
with them
um but social media yeah i've definitely
changed the way i see it and change the
way i want to be
seen on it and
i think it's just stuff
someone might tell you hey you're doing
this wrong with you it's stuff you need
to realize for yourself
um
but social media i think also didn't
help when you win or you lose
you know when you lose the abuse you get
is pretty pretty rough and
you start believing it because when
you're in certain situations
you start like man i'm gonna get like
you're just gonna get abused you know
and
you can look it as a joke and try to be
like yeah yeah it's okay like it's great
it's fine but
the abuse you get does it ends up even
if they are match fixes or whatever you
call them the guys who've been on your
matches it's still
you start what you read is what you know
you start thinking it so
um
yeah i
i just think
it's all
things though like social media and
media and what i read it's all in my
control so that's part of my process is
filtering what i what i do with it um
everything that's happened
and
on my journey has been
my my fault or it's been a you know at
my you know of course it's been at my
cost but it's been my fault and getting
myself out of it again was my fault i've
had a very good support team at the end
of the day whatever bad or good happens
to me it's on me it's in my control
mate it's been super cool to hear
um the deeper side of your story
obviously
um the first episode
this bubbly personality so much fun
sounds such a good lair to be around but
um hearing the deeper side of your story
and what some of the struggles you've
actually had to go through has been
incredibly powerful and like you said at
the start
if one person listening to this can get
something out of it
then it's been 100 worthwhile if it
stopped them from
taking their life or even just helping
them get out of bed or try and fight um
the depression or
mental health issues that they're facing
then
like you mentioned this is definitely
worth it so i really appreciate you
coming on and opening up being
vulnerable
i've got no doubt there'll be a lot of
people
um listening to this who would have
found it very beneficial
awesome thank you so much bro thank you
for hearing uh
my side of things and i'm just hoping
that
you know i can make a change to at least
one person's um
journey
and
that's
all i want to do is show that
someone like me who i like to see myself
as a bubbly person and
very you know
outgoing and
man i talk a lot but
i
everyone goes through battles it's not a
certain person that can suffer from it
it's not someone's fault that they
suffered from it it's just it is what it
is and you have to deal with it
and there's people to help you deal with
it and
call me
someone call me i'll help you like if
you know i'm there's always someone
there because i'll be there so
you can call me
mate you are an absolute lad and there's
no doubt your tennis is gonna be a lot
more beneficial um not having these
shortness of breaths and um this anxiety
going to the match so mate looking
forward to seeing your tennis ranking
climb as well even though it's not all
about that it is about being happy and
living that life but i know you're
driven to become the best tennis player
you can be so and there's no doubt once
you've got that mental part of your game
right um you're going to be a force mate
just out there trying to have a good
time and be the best version of myself
love that absolutely